Donald Trump is still in the business of
throwing childish Tantrums this time
unleashing unleashing the most pathetic
attack so far on Florida Governor
Trump's Governor remember Trump lives in
Florida on his own Governor Ron DeSantis
Donald Trump desperate to find new ways
to attack a guy who is defeating Trump
in some polls despite the fact that Ron
DeSantis hasn't even said I'm running
for this thing he's not even a candidate
and he is ahead of trump significantly
in some polls including the most recent
Monmouth poll this genuinely has the
potential to put the 2016 Republican
party to shame in terms of how
humiliating and absurd this primary
could be Donald Trump on the heels of
this new Monmouth poll that as DeSantis
beating him by 13 which we already
talked about has posted an attack on Ron
DeSantis to his platform truth social
truth essential in which he goes after
Ron DeSantis for wearing a blue tie when
he met with Trump in the Oval Office
while Trump was President well not
exactly let's take a look at the post
from truth social Trump posting a
picture where he is sitting there with
Matt Gates and DeSantis uh and oh who is
I forget who the guy is on the right I
feel so silly but I forget who that is
and Ron DeSantis is wearing a blue tie
and Donald Trump says in his post who is
that in the blue tie being so nice to
the president of the United States while
in the Oval Office now this is not
actually about the tie color this is
about Trump pointing out Ron DeSantis
who now says bad things about me used to
suck up to me
now of course to all of us who
understand how politics works
we understand that that's how politics
works you try to get close to power uh
if you're someone like Ron DeSantis you
want to go to the White House Governors
love going to the White House so of
course you're nice to Trump but Trump
simply can't help but try to find
anything to attack Santa's over recall
that last week
uh he went after DeSantis for this
picture in which DeSantis is with some
allegedly High school-aged girls who I
guess he he was teaching he was the
teacher of and Trump posted that's not
Ron is it he would never do such a thing
referring to grooming high school girls
with alcohol yeah meanwhile in addition
Trump adding to the embarrassment by
tweeting trash polls in response to the
Monmouth poll which has trumped down 13.
Trump tweeting about a premise poll if
you haven't heard of premise as a
pollster they're not even serious enough
to be raided by 538 that one has Trump
up 30 points that seems a little bit
difficult to believe and Trump also
posting a link to a Breitbart poll which
isn't even a poll it's just a
favorability poll it's not an actual
2024 poll it is all completely pathetic
and this is going to be be an insane
primary now I want to oh
I've been wanting to do this for a
little bit
I want to kind of frame the next 21
months for you
if you have read Neil postman's book
amusing ourselves to death I know many
of you were saying David you're not
going to quote technopoly again are you
no this is an earlier book by Neil
Postman it's called amusing ourselves to
death
Postman wrote this book in the mid 80s I
think it was in 85 and what Postman
argued was that if we're going to do a
serious analysis of television and
remember in the mid 80s things were
moving from sort of a print medium
dramatically more towards a visual
Medium television one of the things that
Neil Postman talked about is it's not
just about the content of Television
it's about the fact that television
frames all issues as having to be or
needing to be entertaining Sesame Street
which is a great program right Sesame
Street still implicitly is telling us
learning should be entertaining and it
devalues more difficult forms of
learning that aren't entertaining but
require different type of thought and
one of the things that has become true
not only in the era of Television but
you could take Neil postman's 85
analysis and make it in 2023 when it
comes to to Social and online media one
of the things that has become a reality
is that there is this expectation that
the format of how we get News Today
Twitter and uh the way TV news is
produced and online news as well okay
I'm part of this
we now believe politics should also be
entertaining debates should be
entertaining and that's why primary
debates and presidential debates have
these one-minute answers and 30 second
rebuttals 15 second rebuttals it's not
to actually learn anything about the
candidates in fact it prevents us from
learning about the candidates there are
other ways to learn about the candidates
it tells us politics should be
entertaining these things should be
entertaining and so in a sense I am part
of this
my goal is to work within the formats
that are available to reach as many
people as possible and tell them hey
there are better Ways to Think Through
who we're going to vote for and learn
and say okay so what's the point of me
telling you this one of the things that
we really have to
think about as we go from now into the
primaries and into the general election
is that to really figure out who we
should be voting for What policies would
be better for the country all these
different things you have to exit the
world of where it all needs to be
entertaining the unfortunate reality is
and we're going to talk about the
strategy later or probably tomorrow in
order to defeat Trump and this is the
point I'm building to in order to defeat
Trump Ron DeSantis has to do some of the
things Trump does well he has to be
entertaining he has to attack Trump he
has to be titillating and salacious and
Rhonda santis is going to have to figure
out how it is a horrible thing that on
the one hand we know that all of this is
terrible for the country the fact that
this is how a Republican primary is
going to be fought who can come up with
the slickest insults in the entire thing
I would love to change that I can't
change that
and so when we are thinking through how
Republicans are going to choose their
nominee Democrats to a degree the same
thing but if Biden runs they're not
really going to be choosing it's going
to be Biden it's going to come down to
who can make their campaign as
entertaining and titillating as possible
not who can propose the best policy on
Health Care not who can lay out the most
sober and sensible foreign policy it it
it doesn't make a difference what
matters is
can you compartmentalize it make it a
snippet and make it as entertaining as
possible and that is how politics is
done and it's a sad and horrible thing
and we're going to be looking at this
election through that lens I'm going to
do everything I can to really try to to
to do that because I think it has to be
done all right let's take a quick break
we have many other things to talk about
coming up in mere moments
one of our sponsors is private internet
access most apps and websites send tons
of your personal information to tech
companies and data Brokers based on your
IP address they have a disturbingly
accurate understanding of who you are
and what you do online even when you're
using incognito mode but you can put an
end to it by using a VPN the only one I
use is private internet access because
it's the only VPN that has proven in
court multiple times they are not
logging your activity they're no log
practices are even independently audited
by Deloitte private internet access also
hides your activity from your internet
service provider who is also usually
logging everything you do Online private
internet access is also lightning fast
for downloads and streaming content
normally only available in other
countries private internet access
couldn't be more simple take a second to
download it turn it on that's it you
don't need to know anything about
computers go go to Pia vpn.com Pacman to
get 83 off that's only 203 a month and
you'll get four months free the link is
down below